wo ist dein weg
unsere öffnungszeiten
wir haben von dienstag bis sonntag von 9
bis 23 uhr geöffnet
am montag haben wir leider geschlossen
ja danke tschüss magst du noch eine
limonade liegen ja ich nehme mir noch
eine limonade
es ist 12 uhr und das mittagsangebot
beginnt jetzt hier
was ist denn heute heute gibt es
rouladen mit rotkraut und kartoffeln
oder fisch mit gemüse oder videos
geschnitten so viel vielleicht nehme ich
die in fisch nein die suppe oder warte
die rouladen
ich nehme die rouladen sicher bitteschön
dankeschön entschuldigung wie viel uhr
es dass es ist 12 uhr
du wartest auf lisa oder kommen sie um
viertel nach zwölf oder man hat 1 um
halb zwölf normalerweise fasst marek ist
patrick harand lisa nico ja der ist hier
ok ich sage es nico bis gleich weil das
lisa ja sie kommen um viertel vor eins
also um 12 uhr 45
ich meine sie kommt in 45 minuten das
bewerbungsgespräch dauert länger ok ich
versteh ich bin übrigens tarik hallo ich
bin nico niveau kannst du mir helfen ja
gerne